I want to start with a sincere
congratulations uh this thing turned out
great
um I think that the first thing people
are going to ask after they watch it is
um when are you directing again so I'm
gonna say it when are you directing
again uh hopefully sooner than later
that's that's that's the goal I mean I I
loved every second of it I had a blast I
loved it I mean you know this is a movie
that I've said before but it's a movie
truly that I've been wanting to make
since I was 10 years old you know I've
been making movies since I was like nine
with my Dad's camera and it never
stopped even even throughout my career
as composing I was always making movies
on the side mainly just for me for fun
because I love it you know and uh so I
do hope to continue I do hope to do
something else and you know but you know
to be able to just kind of bring these
characters to life
what better gift you know and especially
characters that I loved as a kid you
know I have a lot of my werewolf By
Night Comics still from when I was a kid
so uh I think a lot of people when they
hear that they're like wait what is
werewolf by night but for me it was just
like what do you mean what is werewolf
By Night how do you miss the one of the
best comic runs ever so uh yeah I love
it I think a lot of people are going to
revisit or learn about it through this
but um I I loved that you put in
cigarette Burns in in the movie and
maybe that's going to appeal to like
five of us but I love it exactly yes um
so was that was that always the the
intention of doing the cigarette Burns
can you sort of talk about why you
wanted to do it uh it was something as
we were editing and stuff you know my
editor Jeff and I are such nerds for
this kind of a thing and we were just
like oh we got to put in those things
too we got to put in the real changes
you know so that you know because we
always approach this as something that
was being done say in the 30s you know
like what would they have done and what
would they have had at their disposable
how would they have done it so we did as
many practical effects in as we could we
built actual sets for everything like
those are all real sets you know
everything you see in there and and our
our visual effects supervisor Joe
Farrell did an incredible job of just
sort of like taking care of the
everything else that we needed but there
weren't like blue screens and green
screens and there weren't like uh sticks
with tennis balls saying hey that's a
monster look at that there was none of
that we had the monster on set you know
we had all of this stuff there was there
for reference and even if we enhanced it
later to some degree it was still on set
for us and that was important I wanted
the actors to feel like they were in a
true environment as opposed to having
not only the work of creating these
characters for us to to to to experience
on film but then they would have to also
imagine what was around them I didn't
want any of that I just wanted them to
be there with everything so all they had
to do was just be the character you got
away with a lot more blood and guts than
I expected I was very surprised and do
you think that happened because you were
shooting it in black and white
I think that helped us it certainly
didn't hurt us uh I think that you know
uh doing something like this
we were able to push a little further
into that direction that we might have
if he had done it any other way you know
um I think people will still be
surprised when they see it you know the
people who are just like turning it on
and say you know but hey that's part of
the fun of it right I I I I felt like
you know as long as it didn't become
sadistic that was our that was our thing
like because I I'm very squeamish
generally I don't like slasher movies
for that reason uh so I didn't wanted to
ever get into that realm where it's just
indiscriminate uh killing everything
needed to have a reason and and and a
why and a how and all of that uh so I do
think that being in black and white
helped us with a lot of that you know
keeping it in that in that realm on that
note I already got to stop I'm just
gonna say congrats and I know people are
gonna love it thank you so much thank
you I'm so glad we'll talk more for sure
have a great day all right talk to you
soon